in deutschland arbeitskräfte fehlen
verändert sich unser leben gerade krass
nicht nur in krankenhäusern und angst
flughäfen merken wir die personal not
nie waren so viele stellen unbesetzt wie
heute 1,74 millionen eigentlich müssten
wir alle mehr arbeiten allerdings wollen
vor allem wegen mehr vom leben aber
unsere gesellschaft veraltet immer mehr
rentner die davon abhängen dass jüngere
arbeiten das gefährdet unseren wohlstand
unsere sozialsysteme
schon bald werden jährlich bis zu
750.000 ältere mehr den arbeitsmarkt
verlassen als auf der anderen seite
jüngere dazu kommen da durch corona
verstärkte personalmangel ist
allgegenwärtig
aber das ist erst der anfang krasse
umbrüche stehen uns in fast allen
branchen bevor
2035 könnten fünf millionen
erwerbstätige fehlen wie schließen wir
diese lücke mit zuwanderung neuen
technologien manche fordern längere
arbeitszeiten andere wollen die vier
tage woche besonders die jüngeren wollen
weniger arbeit und mehr freizeit geht
das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich würde schon sagen ich bin ein
workaholic ich arbeite sehr viel sehr
sehr gerne ich liebe meinen job
natürlich auch wenn 84er baujahr und es
war bei uns ganz normal dass ich auch
als jugendliche mithelfen musste am
marktstand meiner mutter zum beispiel
ich arbeite auch sehr gerne und auch
sehr viel allerdings schon lassen
klassische 40 stunden woche so ein
bisschen ein ausbeuter rheingrenze es
sei denn man kann seine arbeit selbst
bestimmt wählen und flexibel arbeiten so
wie ich bin selbstständig also bin mein
eigener chef aber grundsätzlich will ich
auch schon mehr vom leben als arbeiten
und da bisher mit 27 in ganz typischer
vertreter seiner generation
ich gehöre der sogenannten generation z
an das sind die die zwischen 1995 und
2000 12 geboren sind statt 100 prozent
jobs & karriere wollen sie freizeit und
hohe löhne heißt es über uns angeblich
wollen wir nur drei tage arbeiten lieber
ohne arbeit als unglücklichen job in
deutschland müssen arbeitnehmer innen
derzeit meist gut 40 stunden pro woche
arbeiten
laut einer umfrage wollen dass viele
jüngere aber nicht 53 prozent der
generation set wollen möglichst viel
freizeit haben bei dem baby boom an
geburtsjahrgänge 1955 bis 64 ist nur
knapp ein drittel auf mehr freizeit aus
möglichst viele work-life-balance will
auch jonas manke 25 nach dem abschluss
seines architekturstudiums hat er sich
gegen die klassische karriere
entschieden stattdessen hat er sich mit
freunden ein boot organisiert und ist
mit ihnen um die welt gesegelt auf
youtube hat er das dokumentiert aktuell
finanziert er sein leben vor allem als
freiberuflicher fotograf nebenbei
kümmert er sich um das boot eines
bekannten er will schon bald wieder auf
reisen gehen
ich habe es irgendwie einfach nicht den
bezug zu dieser arbeit und weise wie man
arbeiten muss mich einfach dieses intro
setzen viel statisch aber
pauschal ist es ja in unserer generation
so dass es mehr dazu kommt dass leute
also ein bisschen extravaganz exklusive
machen sachen machen und sich auch
trauen und genau das muss man auch
machen wenn man aus seinem neuen job
rauskommen will was müsst ihr einen
arbeitgeber bieten damit du sagst okay
ich setze mich ins büro ist freiheit
wichtiger als jeden tag jede woche immer
an zu tanzen quasi meldest du auf geld
verzichten wenn es dafür mehr freizeit
und mehr selbstbestimmung für dich geben
würde ich würde auf jeden fall auf geld
verzichten wenn man muss natürlich
irgendwie so eine grundsicherung haben
und in deutschland da ist natürlich die
frage wie auch der standard ist
aber
freiheit ist für mich sowieso wichtiger
als
die freiheit schön und gut aber es gibt
ja auch einfach jobs die gemacht werden
müssen
ich bin in nordhessen in der nähe von
korbach auf der baustelle eines
mittelständischen unternehmens zu den
gut 150 mitarbeitern gehören auch
patrick und sven beide sind mitte
dreißig und haben wie ich eine andere
vorstellung von work life balance als
manch jüngere
einige sagen ach weißt du was ich nehme
lieber weniger geld und weniger sicheres
arbeitsverhältnis aber dafür mehr
freizeit und schon so ein bisschen rum
kannst du das nachvollziehen den ansatz
nachvollziehen kann ich tatsächlich nein
ich will ja irgendwann mal auf was
vorzeigen wenn ich will ja sicherheit da
in meinem leben ich würde meiner familie
sicheres umfeld bieten können auch
finanziell natürlich
da hilft nichts wenn ich wenn ich nach
drei tagen fertig mitarbeit kann mir
nicht leisten dem handwerk fehlt schon
heute eine viertel million arbeitskräfte
tendenz steigend fast ein drittel der
kollegen von sven und patrick gehören zu
den baby boom an und werden in den
nächsten jahren in rente gehen nachwuchs
ist kaum in sicht
das will einfach keiner mehr schwer
anpacken schwer heben schwer arbeiten
wobei das eigentlich auf der baustelle
mit den technischen mitteln heutzutage
zur verfügung stehen auch gar nicht mehr
so ist wie es immer erzählt wird in der
zentrale des bauunternehmens klagte
geschäftsführer darüber dass eine
handwerksausbildung nicht mehr so
wertgeschätzt wird wie früher guck mal
hier jetzt gerade die e mail gekommen
von jemandem der zum ersten acht bei uns
die ausbildung antreten wollte und jetzt
kurzfristig zwei wochen vorher abgesagt
hat weil er doch weiter zur schule gehen
wollte und den akademischen weg
einschlagen wollte ist es eine
begründung für eine absage die du schon
häufiger gelesen hast ja definitiv ich
glaube das spiegelt momentan die
situation im gesamten handwerk und im
baugewerbe wieder dass der
akademisierung grad deutlich erhöht ist
und dass junge menschen eher den
akademischen werdegang einschlagen
wollen als ins handwerk zu gehen
2007 begann noch mehr als 600.000
jugendliche eine berufliche ausbildung
seitdem werden es konstant weniger
zugleich ist im selben zeitraum die zahl
der studierenden stark gestiegen und
bleibt auf hohem niveau
weil es nicht genügend handwerkerinnen
und handwerker gibt sind auch
gesellschaftliche großprojekte gefährdet
wie zum beispiel ausreichend wohnraum
schaffen
wenn man sich die wohnungsbau ziele der
bundesregierung anguckt hältst du das
für realistisch die ziele von 400.000
neue wohnungen pro jahr ist sicherlich
ambitioniert getroffen unter den
aktuellen gegebenheiten ist es
sicherlich schwierig und als nicht zu
realisieren anzuwenden
um als unternehmen attraktiver zu werden
lockt die korbacher firma mit
zusätzlichen anreizen wie einer extra
altersvorsorge und um möglichst viel
zeit mit der familie zu verbringen waren
sven und patrick beide bereits in
elternzeit einen auf dem bau früher
nicht gekannter vorgang
trotz allen erleichterung es liegt noch
viel arbeit vor ihm
17 aus mit dem rentenalter 67 aktuell
ist das ein alter wo du sagst bis 67
kann man schon schlucken auf dem bau
oder ist das totaler wahnsinn also ich
finde es total ein wahnsinn es ist jetzt
gestern zum beispiel wieder ein kollege
krank geworden mit mitte 50 hat sich
wirklich hier gestern muss schon heiß
warum gequält und das ist teilweise
schon echt extrem und bis 67 wer weiß ob
so bleibt also ich muß bis 2007 50
arbeiten das ist doch eine ganz schön
lange zeit ich hoffe ich schaffe aber
ich finde es wirklich zu extrem und
vielleicht wird das rentenalter wie
jetzt wieder gefordert sogar auf 70
jahre erhöht
[Musik]
statt rente mit 70 will siegfried
russwurm präsident des bundesverbands
der deutschen industrie lieber die
wochenarbeitszeit um zwei stunden auf 42
stunden verlängern
auch sigmar gabriel der ehemalige spd
vorsitzende und ex wirtschaftsminister
ist für die 42 stunden um den
personalmangel zu beheben genauso wie
michael hüther der direktor des
instituts der deutschen wirtschaft mit
sitz in köln das ist eine private
wirtschaftsforschung die von arbeitgeber
und industrie verbänden finanziert wird
als chef ratgeber der arbeitgeber wird
michael hüther von medien bezeichnet
sein vorschlag zur 42 stunden woche den
gewerkschaften als billige scheinlösung
ab sie warnen vor überlangen
arbeitszeiten die auf dauer krank machen
können ist das denn auch für jede
branche wird nicht praktikabel
bauarbeiter zb nach sieben stunden
bereits körperlich am ende es kann ja
nicht einfach zwei stunden dran hängen
ohne eben schäden davonzutragen bis 2030
also in nicht allzu langer zeit
verlieren wir alterungsbedingten 4,2
milliarden arbeitsstunden
und wenn die fehlen und die
produktivität nicht entsprechend springt
dann habe problem und diese lücke zu
füllen war die idee
jahresarbeitszeit mit den blick zu
nehmen das wären etwa zwei stunden mehr
woche dass das nach berufen nach
branchen nach sektoren unterschiedlich
sein muss das ist doch völlig klar sie
können auch im pflegebereich nicht
unendlich einfach die dinge verlängern
man muss fragen stimmen die
arbeitsbedingungen im pflegebereich
stimmen die arbeitsbedingungen
tatsächlich nicht an den unikliniken in
nordrhein westfalen haben die pflegenden
zuletzt 79 tage lang gestreikt nicht
etwa für mehr gehalt sondern für mehr
entlastung die ihn nun zugesagt wurde
auch an der uniklinik bonn fehlt überall
personal kaum jemand will noch in den
anstrengenden pflegeberuf
ich treffe hellwig gegner mitte 30
eigentlich hat sie jetzt nach acht
stunden feierabend aber ihre patienten
sind noch nicht ausreichend versorgt und
papierkram hat sie auch noch zu
erledigen
heute zum beispiel hat sich zwei
patienten zu betreuen und meiner
kollegin jetzt im spätdienst sie hat 25
patienten alleine zu betreuen und allein
schon mit meinen zwölf patienten bin ich
ja schon nicht zu rande gekommen
also da wenn ich nach hause gehe bin ich
völlig fertig ich weiß nicht wo ich
damit noch mehr arbeiten soll ich weiß
nicht wie ich da irgendwie dann noch mal
ein normales leben irgendwie dran
kriegen soll was muss denn aus deiner
sicht passieren damit ihr verstärkung
bekommt damit eure teams sich vergrößern
und ihr dann halt nicht mehr so
überarbeitete zeit
es muss ein vernünftiges arbeiten
möglich sein das sind ganz ganz viele
weil sich die sind gegangen weil die die
zustände so katastrophal sind von vielen
weise ich die würden halt auch wieder
zurückkommen wenn sie wüssten sie
müssten sich nicht mehr so total kaputt
arbeiten und wenn sich das ändert
bleiben die halt auch im beruf also für
hellweg ist ihr job tatsächlich eine
berufung die liebt ihre arbeit und da
gibt es ganz ganz vielen leuten so nicht
nur in der pflege die wollen arbeiten
aber es muss halt auch platz für
erholung und für ein bisschen freizeit
bleiben
so sieht das auch johanna winkelbach
wissenschaftliche direktorin der vom
deutschen gewerkschaftsbund finanzierten
hans böckler stiftung eine 42 stunden
woche lehnt sie ab
wenn man sich mal anschaut sieht man
ganz deutlich die wunsch arbeiten sei
ein mensch liegt zwischen 32 und 35
stunden und das liegt einfach daran dass
nur dann ein gutes leben ermöglicht es
sind die menschen ausreichend schlafen
sich um ihre gesundheit kümmern können
und was ich wirklich ganz wichtig wenn
das auch der aspekt der gleichstellung
wer kinder oder pflegebedürftige
angehörige zu versorgen hat und das eine
aufgabe die überwiegend frauen über
neben wenig sagt trägerschaft immer noch
kann nicht 42 stunden arbeiten und diese
menschen werden ausgeschlossen aus dem
arbeitsmarkt frauen investieren täglich
87 minuten mehr zeit in unbezahlte
betreuungsarbeit als männer wenn nun
alle weniger arbeiten würden zum
beispiel in einer voll bezahlten vier
tage woche könnte man sich
betreuungsarbeit besser aufteilen frauen
die häufiger in teilzeit arbeiten müssen
könnten also mit einer gekürzten
vollzeit mehr geld verdienen und werden
gleichzeitig noch besser vor altersarmut
geschützt wie viel wir pro woche
arbeiten müssen darum wurde
jahrzehntelang erbittert gekämpft
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg arbeiteten
beschäftigte in deutschland meist in der
bis heute gesetzlich zulässigen
maximalen arbeitszeit 48 stunden sechs
tage die woche ab mitte der 60er wurde
vermehrt die fünf tage woche eingeführt
der trend gegen jahrzehntelang zur
arbeitszeitverkürzung
doch seit 1991 sind die arbeitsstunden
der vollzeiterwerbstätigen relativ
konstant knapp über 40 stunden im
ausland haben bereits mehrere länder mit
der vier-tage-woche experimentiert in
belgien ist sie seit kurzem sogar
gesetzlich verankert angestellte dürfen
flexibel entscheiden ob sie vier oder
fünf tage pro woche arbeiten wollen bei
gleichem lohn aber auch bei gleichem
arbeitspensum weniger arbeit aber
dasselbe gehalt wie vorher das wird
derzeit in großbritannien ausprobiert
philipp frey leitet mit einem
wissenschaftsteam aus oxford und
cambridge den weltweit größten versuch
zur vier tage woche mehr als 3.300
angestellte aus 70 britischen
unternehmen testen sechs monate das 180
100 modell 100% bezahlung 80 prozent
arbeitszeit und angeblich 100 prozent
produktivität also wohl größer wird wird
insgesamt noch reist viel erledigt
wieder vor und auf der anderen seite
wird durchgehend eigentlich festgestellt
dass die strecke in der belegschaft und
dann zum beispiel auch solchen faktoren
wie die krankenstände die ja auch
unternehmen
in deutschland ist die vier tage woche
noch die absolute ausnahme auf der insel
reichenau im bodensee wird sie von einem
tischlereibetrieb seit einem jahr
umgesetzt täglich arbeiten alle 30
minuten länger freitags ist frei es gibt
24 statt 30 tage urlaub pro jahr
statt knapp 40 arbeitsstunden pro woche
sind es nur noch 37 bei gleichem lohn
trotz geringerer arbeitszeit ist der
umsatz der tischlerei gleich geblieben
überstunden sind zurückgegangen laut dem
chef liegt das daran dass die vier tage
woche alle motiviert besonders effektiv
zu arbeiten die mitarbeiter werden immer
älter und der belastung als schreienesch
nicht unbedingt zu unterschätzen und die
erholungsphase in drei tage ist
natürlich wesentlich größere wir los in
zwei und so war es nur mit ein grund
dass ganze umzusetzen der 20 jährige
nico storz ist einer von 14 mitarbeitern
nico hat abitur die meisten seiner
ehemaligen mitschüler haben sich für ein
studium entschieden er aber hat er
gerade seine tische ausbildung beendet
und wegen der vier tage woche
beschlossen im betrieb zu bleiben also
im handwerk verdient man jetzt nicht
ganz so viel wie wenn man ein studium
abgeschlossen hat und in der höheren
position arbeitet mir ist es sehr
wichtig dass ich spaß an meinem job und
freizeit also zum beispiel nächstes
wochenende fahre ich mit dem kumpel von
donnerstagabend bis sonntag weg das muss
mir dafür keinen urlaub nehmen hast das
gefühl du kommst mit der arbeit
hinterher was jetzt einen tag weniger
kannst du trotzdem genauso viel schaffen
ich will ja keinen großen unterschied
wir arbeiten ja halbe stunde jeden tag
länger und am anfang vom arbeitstag da
arbeitet man ja nicht direkt los
deswegen diese halbe stunde länger ist
im prinzip eigentlich effektiveren die
kunden der tischlerei klingt von der
vier-tage-woche übrigens nichts mehr die
krieger wenigen produkt und gut ist also
in einer tischlerei funktioniert das
allerdings ist das auch nur eine kleine
firma die freitags für ihre kunden einen
telefondienst eingerichtet hat michael
hüther direktor des arbeitgebernahen
instituts der deutschen wirtschaft
bezweifelt dass die vier tage woche auf
die gesamte wirtschaft übertragbar ist
die hoffnung dass man eine
arbeitszeitverkürzung
nutzen kann und automatisch nutzen wird
für einen produktivitäts impuls das war
die diskussion der 80er jahre die 35
stunden woche das hat sich nicht
wirklich bestätigt das
bruttoinlandsprodukt fällt dann geringer
aus hier geht es wirklich um die frage
volkswirtschaftlicher möglichkeiten denn
auch das sollte man mit den augen ins
auge fassen aus all der geben sich
steuer und sozialbeitrag seien damals
all den ergibt sich die möglichkeit
nicht nur sozial politik zu machen
sondern auch um weltpolitik zu machen
wir sehen ja dass das geld selbst in
diesem reichen land nicht einfach nur an
den bäumen hängen sondern es muss
erwirtschaftet werden vertreter meiner
generation zum beispiel dem ist das
bruttoinlandsprodukt nicht so wichtig
von denen es eher wichtig wirklich leben
zu können können sie nachvollziehen dass
viele menschen da erst mal vom kopf
gestoßen sind wenn es heißt du bist war
schon überfordert aber jetzt arbeitet
auch noch mehr damit wie dem brutto
inlandsproduktes besser geht ich weiß
gar nicht wo sie die ganzen
überforderten immer finden die sich in
einer davon ach so ja schon in den
jungen jahren ja das ist ja erstaunlich
also es ist ja nicht so dass die jungen
menschen freiwillig lohn abschläge
hinnehmen also auch das erlebe ich nicht
sondern die haben ganz klare
vorstellungen welche einkommen sie gerne
hätten und diese einkommen soll
marktgerecht seien also dann ist
irgendwie auf einmal marktgerecht
richtig aber klar ist auch ohne
anstrengung passiert nix klar scheint
aber auch dass die jungen ihre
arbeitsbedingungen in zukunft viel
stärker selbst bestimmen können also die
firmen werden sich mehr um sie bemühen
müsse und weil sie so in personal not
sind beauftragen arbeitgeber innen
vermehrt headhunter wie ralf regitz seit
33 jahren vermittelt er im sogenannten
wolford allens im kampf um talente
fachkräfte an und an immobilien und
viele arbeitnehmer sage heute wenn diese
themen wie
freie arbeitszeitgestaltung home office
und alles was es hier gibt nicht gegeben
ist dann sind sie nicht die richtige
arbeitgeber für mich also heißt dass die
menschen früher hatten weniger ansprüche
an ihre arbeitgeber
hatten weniger ansprüche die waren
darüber glücklich wenn sehr gutes geld
verdient haben einen sicheren
arbeitsplatz gehabt haben und
möglichkeiten der weiterentwicklung ums
leben
headhunter rezept auf social media und
vor allem in seinem großen netzwerk um
fachkräfte er verstehe zwar dass meine
generation eine bessere work life
balance möchte glaubt aber nicht dass
wir uns das als gesellschaft leisten
können
letztendlich handelt sich als märz aber
als wir obwohl wir nicht wollen obwohl
wir nicht wollen ja muss dann vielleicht
auch meine generation ein bisschen die
ansprüche zurückschrauben
aus meiner sicht
ja
also wir müssen eine annäherung
wiederfinden dass die unternehmen
weiterhin erfolgreich sind aber auch die
mitarbeiter glücklich sind und ihr geld
verdienen
wäre eine möglichkeit das unternehmen
einfach weniger gewinn machen
das ist eine frage die du gerade an
einen unternehmer stellst du das kannst
du mit weniger gewinn leben wenn ich
dafür mehr erleben kann
wenn leute klar definieren in welchen
umfang sie aber muss man das
entsprechend auch an die arbeitszeiten
und dann das gehaltsmodell anpassen eine
ganz einfache wirtschaftliche aussage
wir besuchen eine fachkraft die ralf
regitz an ein immobilienunternehmen
vermittelt hatte till meyer gehört auch
der generation set an er ist 26 hat
einen master in immobilien management
und arbeitet seit anderthalb jahren seit
ende seines studiums hier in der
unternehmensentwicklung
hast du persönlich was von dem oft
zitierten war for talents mit bekommen
also haben sich arbeitgeber um dich
gerissen ja also zum studienende es ist
dann für mich darum gegen mich zu
bewerben durchaus überrascht dass man
nahezu überall positive rückmeldungen
bekommt und erste gespräche initiiert
werden und über allen doch recht großes
interesse bekundet wurde und was man
natürlich auch im beruf immer noch merkt
man bekommt ständig anfragen von
wildhütern möchtest du nicht hin
wechseln möchtest du nicht dahin
wechseln was ist denn für nicht
besonders wichtig was muss ein
arbeitgeber erfüllen damit gesagt ja da
würde ich arbeiten also ich glaube die
tischtennisplatte und der obst kurzem
mittlerweile etwas abgenutzt
thiel will in seinem job karriere machen
aber zu möglichst angenehmen bedingungen
flexible arbeitszeiten beste technische
ausstattung wohlfühlatmosphäre
deshalb hat er sich für seinen
arbeitgeber entschieden
die personalchefin des unternehmens
zeigt mit dem großen betriebs eigenen
garten in dem regelmäßig firmen feste
gefeiert werden eine tischtennisplatte
gibt es natürlich auch wir brauchen
eigentlich immer mehr arbeitskräfte aber
es sind steht immer weniger zur
verfügung und trotzdem muss arbeit
gemacht werden das wird eine große
herausforderung werden das einzige was
da vielleicht mit positiv auch darauf
ein wird ist einfach so eine digitale
transformation weil damit natürlich auch
viele arbeitsplätze auf dauer wegfallen
werden und sich die ganze arbeitswelt
verändert die digitale transformation
künstliche intelligenz soll die
menschliche arbeitskraft ersetzen und
den personalmangel lindern doch in der
it branche fehlt es derzeit an
fachkräften die die transformation zügig
vorantreiben könnten und längst nicht
immer kann künstliche intelligenz den
menschen ersetzen das institut für
arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung hat den
job fotoroman ins netz gestellt hier
lässt sich ablesen welche berufsgruppen
in welchem maß angeblich von
technologien ausgetauscht werden könnten
bei kassiererinnen kommt man auf
ernüchternde 100% automatisierbarkeit
die kerntätigkeiten von schülerinnen und
schülern sind immerhin zu 58%
automatisierbar pflegekräfte sind nicht
ersetzbar
also egal wie hoch technologisch sich
die welt weiter entwickelt menschen
werden weiterhin gebraucht es stimmt
allerdings veraltet der unsere
gesellschaft also wir werden immer
weniger und das wiederum bedeutet und da
sind sich experten zur abwechslung mal
einig wir brauchen menschen aus dem
ausland also zuwanderung um den
arbeitskräftemangel aufzufangen laut
verschiedener studien braucht
deutschland bis 2035 jährlich mindestens
200 60.000 beschäftigte aus dem ausland
der chef der bundesagentur für arbeit
spricht sogar von 400.000 zuwanderern
pro jahr was aber wenn diese
arbeitskräfte schon bei uns sind
vor einem flüchtlingsheim in leverkusen
treffe ich dr marita harry der vor einem
jahr mit seiner familie aus afghanistan
nach deutschland geflohen ist
die 40 ist arzt gastroenterologe
ab 2020 war er für eine einjährige
fortbildung ins bundeswehrkrankenhaus
nach hamburg eingeladen
anschließend kehrte er in seine heimat
zurück doch kurz darauf übernahm die
taliban die kontrolle über das land
marie wurde mit seiner frau und den
gemeinsamen kindern von der bundeswehr
evakuiert
zum interview in leverkusen hat der
baklava und kuchen mitgebracht marie hat
als flüchtling in deutschland keine
approbation keine zulassung als arzt zu
arbeiten
dafür müsste er zunächst erst fach
sprachkurse belegen die jahrelang dauern
könnten und auf die er seit einem jahr
vergeblich wartet
ganze zeit diesen arbeitslos immer zu
hause das ist katastrophal
und wir wollen natürlich als
arzt arbeiten und zum beispiel meine
frau ist sein als erster und der sie
holt auch
den arbeiten aber leider bis jetzt haben
wir nicht
diesen deutschkurs angefangen was
antworten denn die behörden warum es so
lange dauert das du diese sprachkurse
endlich bekommen kann es um letztendlich
endlich arbeiten zu können in
deutschland das ist eine große frage bei
uns weiß ich nicht das ist problem bye
bye bye bye bürokratie
ja es ist weiß ich nicht was ist der
grund ich kann einfach von ihnen
vergehen was der gewohnt ich wünschte
ich könnte dir beantworten
ich hoffe eine antwort auf dies frage in
bonn zu erhalten bei der
nordrhein-westfälischen zentralstelle
für fachkräfte der einwanderung
schildere ich mal die situation
bürokratische worden das natürlich ein
stichwort das
immer wieder kommt letzten endes und bei
berufen mit approbation und ähnlichem es
ist unheimlich schwierig in den
arbeitsmarkt zu kommen aber das
potenzial ist vergeudet für diejenigen
die erst noch kommen sollen wird
allerdings bereits etwas getan seit 2020
gibt es dass fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz es soll die
zuwanderung von arbeitskräften von
außerhalb der eu fördern neun von 16
bundesländern haben seitdem solche
behörden wie in bonn die arbeitgeber zum
beispiel bei visa angelegenheiten
unterstützen sollen allerdings die
offizielle vermittlung der bundesagentur
lockte im vorjahr gerade einmal gut
3200 ausländische fachkräfte nach
deutschland weit entfernt von den
260.000 die angeblich mindestens jedes
jahr benötigt werden wo liegt jetzt das
größte problem
ich glaube das größte problem ist
einfach paare zu sehen dass die
[Musik]
einreise verfahren noch nicht optimal
strukturiert sind
aber auch dass die arbeitgeber
verpflichtet sind ihre fachkräfte im
ausland selber zu suchen natürlich gibt
es hilfestellungen durch die
bundesagentur für arbeit aber letzten
endes ist es eben tatsächlich die
originäre aufgabe eines unternehmens
nicht um die beschäftigten selber zu
kümmern und das ist ein faktor wo viele
noch nicht wirklich das umsetzen was sie
sich vielleicht vor einigen jahren schon
vorgenommen haben also das problem ist
erkannt auch von den behörden und einige
von denen arbeiten sogar mit
zukunftsforscher innen an strategien die
man den personalmangel auf allen ebenen
beheben kann eine solche
zukunftsforscherin treffe ich in
paderborn im größten computer museum der
welt hannah jürgensmeier ist
geschäftsführerin eines unternehmens das
bereits bundesämter sowie mehrere
dax-konzerne bei der zukunftsgestaltung
beraten im museum zeigt eine ausstellung
arbeitsplätze aus der vergangenheit
früher gab es zeitweise
massenarbeitslosigkeit noch 2005 waren
in deutschland fast fünf millionen
menschen ohne beschäftigung
diese zahl hat sich bis heute halbiert
zukunftsforscher in hanoi jürgensmeier
glaubt dass viele der aktuell knapp
zweieinhalb millionen arbeitslosen den
personalmangel mit auffangen könnten es
gibt ganz ganz viele bereiche für die
diese menschen die gerade nicht in
arbeit sind sich interessieren und ich
glaube dass wir ganz ganz viele
motivieren können vielleicht auch nicht
in vollzeit vielleicht nicht in so
starren strukturen wie wir sie uns heute
so als festen job als arbeitswelt
vorstellen aber ich sehe da durchaus
möglichkeiten dieses potenzial noch zu
schöpfungen um arbeitslose wieder zu
integrieren braucht es also klügere
lösungen als bisher so wie es insgesamt
neue modelle für die zukunft der arbeit
braucht um offene stellen zu besetzen
die eine zukunft gibt es leider nicht
dass es ist sehr enttäuschend für alle
menschen die das gerne wissen möchten
wir haben es aber sogar schon geschafft
dass im duden inzwischen zukünftig steht
und das ist einfach der tatsache
geschuldet dass die welt sehr komplex
ist sich viele dinge ständig verändern
aber das ist natürlich auch eine
riesenchance denn wir können gerade sehr
sehr viel gestalten denn es gibt im
moment die mobilitäts wende die
energiewende und es gibt technologien
die vor dem durchbruch stehen oder schon
angewendet werden wir werden sicherlich
mittel und wege finden die arbeit anders
zu verteilen und ein lebenswertes leben
zu gestalten und das sollten wir
gemeinsam in angriff nehmen die
zukunftsforscherin klingt ja erstmal
sehr optimistisch also sie spricht von
wandel von veränderungen also man kann
den arbeitskräftemangel sogar als chance
begreifen man könnte alte strukturen
aufbrechen gerade in den bereichen
zuwanderung oder was die
gleichberechtigung angeht was ich gut
finde ist dass gerade die arbeitnehmer
innen am längeren hebel sitzen klar
verstehe ich die rechnung weniger
arbeitende gibt dann muss der rest eben
mehr arbeiten aber mir fehlt also der
factor live ja gut also wenn die
jüngeren nicht genauso viele oder mehr
stunden arbeiten wollen die ältere
generation
dann müssen wir alle effizienter
arbeiten um mehr live zu haben also sei
es jetzt durch eine vier-tage-woche
flexiblere arbeitszeiten oder auch durch
neue technologie wie seht ihr das
diskutieren gerne mit unter dem hashtag
grauzone
[Musik]
[Applaus]